good evening the details for saturday's
funeral for the duke of edinburgh have
just been announced a service that in
keeping with the covid restrictions
being observed by the entire country
will be limited to just 30 guests
alongside the queen will be the couple's
children
and grandchildren as well as members of
prince philip's own
royal family in germany let's take a
more detailed look
the queen will be accompanied by a lady
in waiting as she is driven
behind the coffin the duke's children
prince charles
princess anne prince andrew and prince
edward will all be attending
they'll be socially distant will wear
face masks and will not
sing his grandchildren will also be in
attendance including the duke of sussex
who has flown over from the u.s for the
event
members of the family will not be
wearing a military
uniform let's bring in our royal
correspondent to
rhiannon mills and uh rhiannon very
difficult of course this for
the queen limiting uh the funeral to 30
mourners but who will be there apart
from those we've just mentioned
so i think you're right mark it was
always going to be of interest to see
exactly
how they managed to strip down that
congregation to just include
30 people when you think that the queen
and the duke have
four children eight grandchildren ten
great-grandchildren
and you won't be surprised to hear of
course that all of the children
their partners also all of the
grandchildren their partners are all
included
in that congregation but also there on
the list that we've been given
over the last few hours are princess
margaret's two children you also have
three of the queen's cousins they're
also included and one of prince philip's
cousins the countess mountbatten of
burma and also some names that people
probably aren't so familiar with we also
have
three of prince philip's german
relatives so
two great nephews and also a cousin
of prince philippa also all included now
in terms of those who've traveled over
from germany
we understand that they have been
abiding by all of the government
regulations when it comes to
isolating because of covid but they are
of course allowed to attend
uh the funeral on the weekend but yeah
it is very much
a family affair of course in any other
time any other year you would have
expected
hundreds of people to attend the funeral
of the duke of edinburgh but because of
covid
that very small 30 congregation
all of whom will fit inside and the
choir that very intimate space
inside saint george's chapel and we're
told that any members of staff who are
anywhere near the chapel they're simply
there to make sure that
proceedings run as they should we're
also given a few more details
about the funeral procession and also
the service
um as well so we know that it's going to
be the prince of wales and princess anne
who will
lead some of that procession of other
members of the family
of course also prince william prince
harry are going to be involved between
them however as they're walking will be
their cousin peter phillips also we now
know that the queen will travel by car
behind the coffin she'll be in that car
with
a lady in waiting also as other people
who are carrying out funerals at the
moment
there will be social distancing in place
also
all the congregation will wear face
masks and they will not
sing um but also we've been getting more
details about
the ways that prince philip um has been
involved in in shaping his own funeral
and some new pictures have been released
of that rather
unique vehicle which will carry his
coffin during that procession
so this land rover that he helped to
design which i think is
a lovely touch for a man that we've
often spoken about this week haven't we
about how
modern and radical he could be at times
so yeah a few more details about the
funeral which will take place
on saturday but of course we keep being
reminded this is a very important family
occasion this is still a family uh in
mourning at the moment but hugely
appreciative of all the messages they've
had
from across the uk and around the world
remembering a man that meant so much to
them
yeah and a lot of speculation rhiannon
obviously about his
german relatives and as you say there
are
i'm just seeing a three i think there
which is uh which is interesting of
itself
it is but i think a lot of people will
reflect back on on the time when
um prince philip married um princess
elizabeth and actually at the time his
german relatives weren't
welcome to that wedding it was so soon
after the second world war
and some of his sisters of course um
held spouses who had nazi links so
there was this suspicion about them
understandably and so they weren't
invited to the wedding but i think
um over the years we have seen the queen
and the duke make visits to germany
and yeah i think it is that that
reflection of this being a family affair
of course we're so used to talking about
those senior royals here in the uk but
i think really lovely to see that some
of um prince phillips side the family
have also been invited but we kept being
reminded today just how involved
prince philip had been in the planning
but ultimately it's the queen who has
had to
to sign off these final plans and also i
think one thing that is worth mentioning
um is that none of the family are going
to wear military uniform
and that in itself is interesting of
course there is going to be an enormous
military presence um certainly inside
the castle grounds here at windsor we
keep being reminded that all of that
ceremony is going to take place
away from from the public inside the
castle grounds
but interestingly that the family are
not wearing military uniforms you would
of course expect that usually with
with a big ceremonial funeral like this
but i think the queen and others within
the family have decided that
it's best that they wear morning dress
with medals
i think to make sure there isn't too
much attention on
as you could describe it recent family
differences
and those within the family who have
stepped away from royal duties
and had to step away from their military
titles i think for the family
the attention very much has to be on the
duke of edinburgh
and they do not want too much discussion
about problems that have happened within
the family
certainly over the last year a year or
so
absolutely rhiannon thank you very much
indeed